METEOROLOGIST SAYING GERMANY
SAW ITS HEAVIEST RAINFALL ON A
CENTURY, IN ONE DISTRICT ALONE,
1300 PEOPLE ARE, ASSUMED
MISSING, AND FLASH FLOODS.
55 DEAD ACROSS WESTERN GERMANY,
AND BELGIUM, HIT HARD.
SOME REGIONS RECEIVING MORE
THAN A MONTH'S WORTH OF RAIN,
IN 24 HOURS.
ITALY, FRANCE, SENDING TEAMS TO
HELP WITH THE CLEANUP.
EXPERTS SAY IT IS BECOMING MUCH
MORE COMMON, AS THE PLANET GETS
WARMER.
>> NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
IT IS INCREDIBLE.
FRANKLY, I NEVER THOUGHT I
WOULD SEE IT IN BELGIUM.
>> WE ARE AFRAID.
WE ARE PANICKING.
MADONNA ARE SUPPOSED TO COME
HOME TODAY, IT'S STRESSFUL, AND
ANXIETY.
WE CAME HOME FROM WORK BECAUSE
WE ARE NOT SAFE, AND IT'S
SCARY.
WE'VE NEVER KNOWN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
>> CNN IT'LL CENTRAL, STREAMING
US LIVE FROM LONDON.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THESE DRAMATIC SCENES,
UNFOLDING IN GERMANY, THE
NETHERLANDS, BELGIUM, AND
LUXEMBOURG.
THESE COUNTRIES, WHERE RIVERS
HAVE BURST THEIR BANKS THANKS
TO A LOW PRESSURE WEATHER
SYSTEM, LINGERING OVER THIS
PART OF EUROPE, FOR SOME TIME.
DUMPING, AS YOU, SAID HEAVY
RAINFALL.
WE TOOK 2000 MILLIMETERS AND 9,
HOURS HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
OBSERVE THAT BIG BURST, WITH
TRAGIC CONSEQUENCES.
IN FACT, JUST TO POINT, OUT THE
MOST POPULOUS PARTS OF GERMANY,
IS ONE OF THE 2 REGIONS WHERE
THE DEATH TOLL IS THE HIGHEST.
2 REGIONS OF GERMANY, IN
PARTICULAR, AFFECTED, PROMPTING
THE LOSS OF NEARLY 5000 LIVE SO
FAR, BUT AS YOU POINTED, OUT
SCHOOLS OF MISSING PEOPLE AT
THIS POINT, AUTHORITIES JUST
CAN'T REACH, BECAUSE MOBILE
PHONE NETWORKS ARE DOWN.
I DID THE REALTIME, THESE ARE
THE SCENES AGREE TO GERMANY,
AND THOSE OTHER COUNTRIES.
ONE SET ANGELA MERKEL, THE
GERMAN CHANCELLOR, WAS WATCHING
FROM AFAR.
AT THE MOMENT, SHE FINDS
HERSELF IN WASHINGTON, ON A
STATE VISIT.
>> TORRENTIAL RAIN, SEVERE
FLOODING, ACROSS EUROPE.
LEAVING DOZENS DEAD, AN
EXTENSIVE DAMAGE IN THEIR WAKE.
RIVERS, OVERFLOWING THEIR BANKS,
HOUSES COLLAPSED, ROADS WERE
WASHED AWAY, AND A MUDDY MESS
LEFT BEHIND.
PARTS OF GERMANY, RECEIVING
OVER 200 MILLIMETERS OF RAIN,
IN JUST 9 HOURS.
2 FIREFIGHTERS, AMONG THE DEAD
THERE.
OTHERS, LEFT WITH NOTHING.
>> ARE THESE PEOPLE LIVING HERE,
I KNOW THEM WELL.
I FEEL SO SORRY FOR THEM.
THEY HAVE LOST EVERYTHING.
ALL THEY HAVE AS WHAT THEY HAD
AUTUMN.
IT'S GONE, AFFIRMED HAD A
WORKSHOP OVER THERE, NOTHING
STANDING.
THE BAKERY, THE BUTCHER, IT IS
ALL GONE.
IT'S SCARY, UNIMAGINABLE.
THIS DRAMATIC SCENE, AND
WESTERN GERMANY, AS SOME PEOPLE
LIVE STRANDED ON THE ROOFTOPS,
WERE RESCUED BY HELICOPTERS.
ACROSS THE BORDER, IN BELGIUM,
THIS MAN BRAVED THE WATER TO
CHECK ON HIS NEIGHBORS.
ALMOST REACHING THEIR WINDOWS.
THIS VILLAGE, DEVASTATED.
HOMES ARE COLLAPSED, SWALLOWED
UP BY THE RISING WATER.
ONE MAN SAYS, HE IS WORRIED
ABOUT HIS FAMILY.
>> MY MOTHER, STUCK IN A HOUSE
OVER THERE, WITH MY BROTHERS,
AND MY SISTERS.
THE WALLS OF THE HOUSE,
STARTING TO CRACK.
THE HOUSE, AT RISK OF COLLAPSE.
>> IN THE NETHERLANDS, A CARE
HOME WAS EVACUATED DURING THE
STORM.
THEY HOPE TO GET OVERLY
RESIDENTS TO SAFETY, DURING THE
FACILITY WITH ELECTRICITY WITH
OTHER SUPPLIES.
VISITING WASHINGTON ON THURSDAY,
THE GERMAN CHANCELLOR, ANGELA
MERKEL, SAID THAT SHE IS
THINKING OF THOSE IN HER
HOMELAND.
>> THESE ARE TERRIBLE DAYS FOR
THE PEOPLE IN THE FLOODED
AREAS.
MY THOUGHTS ARE WITH YOU, AND
YOU CAN TRUST, ALL FORCES OF
OUR GOVERNMENT, FEDERAL,
REGIONAL, AND COMMUNITY,
COLLECTIVELY, WILL DO
EVERYTHING UNDER MOST OF LOCAL
CONDITIONS TO SAVE LIVES,
ALLEVIATE DANGERS, AND RELIEVED
TO STRESS.
>> SURE TO GERMANY'S MILITARY
TO HELP AND SOME OF THE HARDEST
HIT AREAS.
A GERMAN METEOROLOGIST SAYING,
IN SOME AREAS, THEY HAVEN'T
SEEN THIS MUCH RAINFALL IN 100
YEARS.
AND, THE COUNTRY IS IN FOR MORE
BAD NEWS.
WEATHER FORECASTERS, SAYING
THAT ADDITIONAL RAINFALL IS
EXPECTED, IN SOUTHWESTERN
GERMANY, IN THE DAYS TO COME.
>> THAT TYPE OF HELP WILL BE
NEEDED THERE.
15,000 GERMAN TROOPS, BEING
DEPLOYED TO SOME OF THESE
STRICKEN AREAS, TO HELP RESCUE
PEOPLE FROM CRUMBLING
BUILDINGS.
WE HAVE ALSO, AS YOU SAID, HAD
SUPPORT FROM THE ITALIAN AIR
FORCE, AND ALSO FRANCE AS WELL.
THE UK, STANDING READY TO HELP.
IT'S AS MESSAGES OF CONDOLENCES
HAVE BEEN FLOODING IN FROM
VLADIMIR PUTIN OF RUSSIA, TO
POPE FRANCIS.
THE REALITY, HOWEVER, IS THAT
GERMANY WILL NEED AN AWFUL LOT
OF MONEY TO REBUILD, ONCE THIS
RESCUE EFFORT IS UNDERWAY.
THIS WILL ALSO, AS YOU POINT
OUT, SEE THE CLIMATE CHANGE IN
GERMANY, AS WE HEAD TOWARDS THE
ELECTIONS IN THE 26TH OF
SEPTEMBER.
OF COURSE, THIS IS ANGELA
MERKEL'S LAST YEAR IN OFFICE.
>> A LOT HAPPENING, THANK YOU.
LIVE AT THIS HOUR, IN LONDON,
WE APPRECIATE IT.
DEREK VAN DAMME, WITH MORE ON
THIS CASE THAT HAS BEEN RUNNING
THERE FOR DAYS.
WHAT IS THE FORECAST LOOKING
LIKE?
>> THE WORST OF THE RAIN,
STARTING TO MOVE TO THE SOUTH,
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE
PRECIPITATION IS DONE.
JUST GOING TO PIGGYBACK ON WHAT
NINA SAID, A MOMENT AGO, IT'S
THESE HIGH ENERGY, SUDDEN
TORRENTS OF SUMMER RAIN, THAT
IS WHAT WE WOULD EXPECT TO SEE
IN A WARMING CLIMATE, RAPIDLY
WARMING, LIKE WE EXPERIENCE
NOW.
WARMER AIR HOLDS MORE WATER
VAPOR, WATER VAPOR HAS A CHANCE
TO UNLEASH MORE RAINFALL, AND
WHEN THAT INTERSECTS WITH THE
POPULAR AREA, THAT IS
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT TOOK PLACE.
I AND IT IS THE ATMOSPHERE IN
EUROPE, AND WHAT THEY DID IS
THEY STARTED TO MAP OFF THE
FLOODED AREAS.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT LEGION,
BELGIUM, THIS IS THE RIVER THAT
RUNS TO THE SOUTH, AND THROUGH
THIS PARTICULAR TOWN.
THIS IS LIGHT BLUE IN THE TOWN,
WHERE THE RIVER FLOODED.
IT IS OVER FLOODING IT'S RIVER
BANKS.
YOU CAN SEE THE EXTENSIVE
NATURE OF THE FLOODING.
INJUSTICE TOWN IN BELGIUM, IT
IS THE LOCATION HIT HARDEST.
WE WENT BACK 48 HOURS, ON THE
RADAR, AND THIS IS THE
PRECIPITATION THAT TOOK PLACE.
LOOK AT HOW IT TRAINS OVER THE
SAME LOCATION, FOR SEVERAL
HOURS AT A TIME.
BELGIUM, WESTERN GERMANY,
LUXEMBOURG, THOSE ARE THE AREAS
HIT HARDEST BY THIS TORRENT OF
PRECIPITATION, ALL THANKS TO
WHAT'S CALLED, A CUT OFF, LOW
PRESSURE SYSTEM.
THIS IS WATER VAPOR ENERGY, AND
YOU CAN SEE HOW THE LOW SPINS,
IN THE SAME LOCATION.
IT IS CUT OFF FROM THE GENERAL
FLOW OF THE ATMOSPHERE.
IT IS NOWHERE TO GO, IT SITS IN
THE SAME LOCATION, THAT IS WHAT
PRODUCES THIS EXCESSIVE AMOUNT
OF RAINFALL TOTALS AND OVER 2
AND MILLIMETERS IN 9 HOURS.
THEY AVERAGED NEARLY THE
MONTHLY AVERAGE OF THE
LOCATION.
LOOK AT THAT JET STREAM,
CUTTING OFF THE FLOW, AND IT
PILES UP LIKE TOY CARS.
WE DID SOME MATH, HERE AND IT
ONLY TAKES, ROUGHLY, AROUND 15
CENTIMETERS, PER PERSON, TO BE
SWEPT OFF THEIR FEET BY MOVING
WATER.
BUT, 60 CENTIMETERS OF MOVING
WATER, ACTUALLY FLOWING TO THE
VEHICLE, TO SEND IT COMING DOWN
SOME OF THESE ROADWAYS, TURNING
INTO RIVERS DURING THESE
FLOODING EVENTS.
JOHN?
>> WE APPRECIATE THE UPDATE.
DEREK AND, DOWN WITH THE
LATEST.
A NASA STUDY, WARNING THAT
COASTAL FLOODING WILL BE MUCH
MORE FREQUENT BY THE MID 20
THIRTIES.
THAT'S NOT JUST BECAUSE OF
RISING SEA LEVELS FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE.
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NEXT
DECADE, THE LUNAR CYCLE WILL
FLIP INTO A PHASE THAT
AMPLIFIES TIDES.
IT IS CALLED THE MOON WOBBLE.
THAT MEANS THAT HIGH TIDES WILL
GET HIGH, AND LOW TIDES WILL
GET LOW.
THEY'RE EXPECTING TO SEE A
CLIMATE DRIVEN RISING SEA
LEVELS BY THEN, SEEING THAT
SOME COASTAL CITIES WILL SEE
FLOOD SEASONS LASTING A MONTH,
OR LONGER.
DURING THIS TIME, AFFECTED
AREAS COULD FLOOD EVERY COUPLE
OF DAYS.
THE ATMOSPHERIC SCIENTISTS,
TALKED ABOUT THE LUNAR CYCLE,
AND HOW MUCH WORSE THAT THIS
COULD ALL MAKE COASTAL
FLOODING.
>> SEA LEVEL WILL BE A BIT
HIGHER, AND IT DEFINITELY IS
INCREASING.
IT'S ACCELERATING.
THE INCREASE IS SPEEDING UP.
THAT WILL CONTINUE, AS LONG AS
WE CONTINUE TO WARM UP THE
PLANET.
IT IS SOMETHING THE SUPER STORM
SANDY, AND IT STRUCK NEW YORK
CITY.
IT IS THE PEAK OF A HIGH TIDE.
SO, IT WAS ONCE A PERFECT STORM,
AND IF YOU PARDON THE
EXPRESSION, THERE WILL BE SEA
LEVEL RISE, A BIGGER, STRONGER
STORM, THEN WE HAVE SEEN, THAT
FAR NORTH, THAT LATE IN THE
SEASON.
AND, IT HAPPENED AT HIGH TIDE.
ALL OF THESE CAME TOGETHER TO
GIVE US THE 14 FOOT STORM SURGE,
BATTERY PARK THAT, LITERALLY,
FLOODED LARGE PARTS OF UPPER
MANHATTAN.
SO, THIS IS SORT OF THE SAME
IDEA, BUT IT'S PLAYING OUT ON A
LONGER TIME.
YOU HAVE SEA LEVEL RISE, YOU
HAVE STRONGER STORMS, AND
BIGGER STORM SURGES, AND THEN
JUST BECAUSE OF THE NATURAL
CYCLE, NOT THE SHORT TERM HIGH
TIDE, AND THE OTHER HIGH TIDE,
IT WILL ADD TO ALL OF THOSE
STORM SURGES.
ALONG WITH SEA LEVEL RISE.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS.
IT GETS A LITTLE HIGHER, EACH
TIME, AND ALL IT TAKES IS A FEW
EXTRA INCHES TO FLOOD LARGER,
AND LARGER AREAS.
IN FACT, THE 12 INCHES OF SEA
LEVEL, IN NEW YORK CITY, THUS
FAR, BECAUSE OF GLOBAL WARMING.
A LITTLE LESS THAN 12 INCHES.
THERE IS 25 ADDITIONAL SQUARE
MILES OF LETTING THE SUPER
STORM SANDY.
NOW, WE TALK ABOUT THE SAME
PHENOMENON, BUT WRIT LARGE,
ALONG THE COAST LINES OF ALL OF
THE MAJOR CONTINENTS.
AND, THE LOW LYING ISLAND
NATIONS AS WELL.
IT IS A GLOBAL EFFECT.
SO, COASTLINES AROUND THE WORLD,
COASTAL COMMUNITIES AROUND THE
WORLD, AGAIN, THE BIG PROBLEM
HERE IS CLIMATE CHANGE, SEA
LEVEL RISE, BIGGER STORM SURGES
FROM LARGER, STRONGER STORMS.
THIS WILL GIVE IT THE EXTRA
LITTLE BIT.
JUST A FEW EXTRA INCHES, AND
JUST ENOUGH TO, POTENTIALLY,
FLOOD FAR LARGER REGIONS.
SO, IT IS A REMINDER, THERE ARE
SURPRISES IN STO